I just thought it was a really beautiful
script my policeman may have drawn some
early criticism after Harry Style
or the screen anyway let's talk about
the behind the scenes stories that
helped make my policeman so touching he
knows who he is
incredibly proud number one you can say
a lot with a Simple Touch director
Michael grandage brought on
choreographer and frequent collaborator
Ben Wright to help add an extra layer of
intimacy to nearly every scene in my
policeman Wright would train the actors
as intimacy coordinator taking special
care with every small touch between them
and he even choreographed the love
scenes to make them feel almost like a
dance
I can't then I'll do it I'll tell her
number two talk about a whirlwind
meeting the first day that Emma Corin
David Dawson and Harry Styles arrived on
set the three actors were thrown into a
sound booth and made to sing around a
piano Corin would later reflect on the
experience as being a really clever way
of breaking the ice Styles in particular
felt very at home in the sound booth
because it was like a recording studio
which is Harry's natural habitat his
confidence probably helped his co-stars
quite a bit because as Corin would add
we both were scared let's have a toast
to marry me no and to all of us number
three our leads had to get real close
during rehearsals quarantine had a
massive effect on the way that my
policeman was filmed with the cast even
performing their initial meet and greet
through Zoom rehearsals were often done
in groups of three meaning that our
leads got to know each other pretty well
before they even got to filming Emma
Corin would later comment on how this
definitely had an effect on the Trio's
on-screen chemistry stating that things
might have been different if they
rehearsed in groups of six the audience
wasn't buying into their friendship then
the Fallout of everything in the way
that they deceive each other wouldn't
hit the same way number four this was a
full-time job fans of Harry Styles may
know that he has plenty of tattoos 56 at
least and every single one of those
tattoos needed to be covered with
airbrushing by a team of three makeup
artists as the film's hair and makeup
designer Daniel Phillips pointed out the
story is set within an era where
regulation for policemen would not have
a allowed tattoo artwork to such an
extent and so plenty of time was spent
to make sure that he believably looked
the part
I can't draw you if I don't know who you
are
right
number five one book can change your
life that's certainly the case for
producer Robbie Rogers who came up with
the idea of adapting my policeman after
reading it during a time when he had
been struggling with his own identity I
kind of feel like the book found me
Rogers then approached the author bethan
Roberts about his idea of turning it
into a movie and she could tell that he
really loved the book and it meant a lot
to him personally so it felt like okay
you're going to protect it there's so
much passion in his work
number six what's more important
historical accuracy or fashion although
costume designer Annie Simon spent
plenty of time looking through old path
a newsreels and family photos for
inspiration she ultimately decided to
opt for costumes that would suit the
actors best the policeman's uniform that
Harry Styles wears in the film is a more
inviting and Youthful blue rather than
the traditional black for instance which
Simon's felt would have looked too
authoritarian number 7. my policeman is
sure one stunning movie much of the
novel is set in Brighton and so the film
shot on location using famous English
landmarks like Palace Pier as well as a
few buildings of historical significance
like the Royal Pavilion the scenes that
find Tom and Patrick completely free
exploring Venice together were actually
shot in Venice as well which is actually
where filming wrapped at the end of the
three weeks number eight this is not the
must-watch list we were expecting in an
interview with Entertainment Weekly
grandage admitted that he took
inspiration from films such as the 1963
black and white drama the servant
especially with its use of mirrors as
well as the 1973 horror film don't look
now this latter movie included a love
scene that was somewhat controversial at
the time of its release and grandage was
hoping to capture a similar level of
intimacy I could bring some a sort of
personal voice Beyond just the um
director's Voice number nine so is the
movie author approved Beth and Roberts
has made it no secret that my policeman
is her favorite work to date and so if
anyone should be a harsh critic to
please it should be her and yet Roberts
has described the whole experience as
being overwhelming considering how long
she's dreamed of seeing it happen
Roberts has said that Harry Styles is
perfect for Tom and she's expressed a
lot of respect for Emma Corin as an
actor while describing David Dawson as
Patrick as terrific hello
here I am just as promised number 10
talk about different takes what was it
that made Rupert Everett's performance
as the mute Patrick so moving well if
you ask grandage he'd say that the
credit goes entirely to Everett who was
able to evoke some pretty intense
emotions using his face even if he
didn't have much of a script to work
with his expressiveness as an actor was
still there Everett on the other hand
gave all of the credit for his
performance to the other Talent on set
stating most of my work is done for me
by the other actors I really just have
to sit there and reap the benefits
because the idea is so poignant then did
become a project of passion I suppose
after a bit number 11 these things tend
to happen and when you're running late
David Dawson and Gina Mckee only had
about 10 minutes to pick up the best
Ensemble award at the film's premiere
when they wound up getting stuck in the
elevator for about 30 minutes it wasn't
all bad though McKee would later recall
the event by stating that Dawson was
definitely the person you want to call
on in case of emergency I mean just so
collected very impressive number 12 Emma
Corin wasn't the casting director's
first choice for Marion Lily James was
originally in talks for the role when
the movie was first announced but when
James stepped aside attention then went
to Emma Corin who recently shined on the
crown as Princess Diana grandage would
later say that Corrin was perfect for
the role because she brings an honesty
and simplicity that comes from a very
open place number 13. it's hard to find
a star usually directors are forced to
reach out to actors to fill a role but
it was actually Harry Styles who
contacted Michael grandage through his
agent specific requesting the role of
Tom grandage wasn't at all put off by
Styles's relative inexperience simply
because Styles was able to prove that
he'd done his research and that he was
incredibly passionate about the role I
feel incredibly lucky to have been a
part of such an amazing Story number 14
did you know my policeman is based on a
true story although Patrick Tom and
Marion are fictional Beth and Roberts
took plenty of inspiration from the real
life of writer Ian Forster for her novel
Forester fell in love with a married
policeman who was 46 years his Junior
and he even went to live with this
policeman and his wife when he fell
fatally ill in 1970. the letters written
by the three during this time reveal an
intense love between them and Roberts
wanted to explore how such a love would
grow number 15 maybe he could have
worded this better when discussing my
policeman in a 2022 interview with the
Rolling Stones Harry Styles Drew
criticism when he stated that the love
scenes would be more romantic in nature
than anything we've seen in similar
movies this led some to accused styles
of being less aware of the marginalized
Community he claims to represent than he
should be with some even accusing him of
Faking his identity for clout Stiles
responded by pointing out that he's
never publicly discussed his
relationships because he prefers to keep
his love life private it seems the
entire cast of my policeman truly did
have a lot of fun filming it and their
time together has only formed a deeper
Bond how do you think that translated
onto the big screen could you feel a
genuine love between these characters
let us know down in the comments